hello i am drew barrymore's resident
astrologer elisa kelly and i am so
excited for another episode of horoscope
it out i am with mr rossi ross matthews
yes i know this is a big deal i can't
believe you booked
me mr rossi ross thank you welcome to my
show
[Music]
i'm so excited to be on it and you know
i'm we're obsessed with what you do and
so we were talking about the horoscopes
of so many celebrities like you do on
your show and i said would you do me so
here we are exclusively for the due
barrymore website it's really exciting
to get to see
the chart it explains why you and drew
work together so well
yes so let's start with your sun sign
your sun represents
your identity it's your ego it's how you
take up space it's how you interact with
the world the sun is really sort of like
the you that we are experiencing and
it's in libra so libra is all about
balance it's a very social sign so it's
interested in how can you counterbalance
adjust calibrate to support whatever is
there you know so in this case obviously
this makes you such an amazing partner
for drew
because you can offer whatever she needs
you can balance her you can work
together you can harmonize you pull it
up well rossi thank you this is not
doing anything for me right now and i
will echo you that's not doing anything
for you right now
so this is based on like what
when i was born
so it's time date and location of birth
so you got that information and from
that you do
and you can figure out
like what makes me tick yeah so my son
is a libra
and that you're saying the that that
makes me like able to pivot
energetically and all that stuff yeah i
mean i think anyone that interviews or
or is inquisitive has to do that anybody
who hosts like i do you have to sort of
read the room and adjust right what's
bradley cooper up close one word to
describe him gorgeous hmm give me
another word too deep voice wow we got
three words we got three you also have
the sun in your 11th house no it's my
11th house in palm springs
[Laughter]
sun
venus
mercury and pluto are all in libra in
your 11th house what does that mean so
it means that we have a cluster of
energy which we call a stellium
and a stellium is a concentration right
it's something where that area shows up
in a very pronounced way in your chart
so all of those planets in libra which
is all about that balance and harmony
really show that that defines your
spirit and the birth chart is very
complex so in addition to being a sun in
libra you are also a scorpio rising and
a scorpio moon did you know that no this
is very interesting because there seems
to be something on this drew barrymore
show where there is a lot of water moon
energy
drew barrymore has a cancer moon tom
green had a scorpio moon i have a pisces
moon
and you have a scorpio moon as well and
we all have watermelons we're all very
empathic what you mean by that is like
we are able to feel what people are
feeling and
put ourselves in their shoes yeah we
feel their pain we feel their joy
yeah not everybody feels that
interesting i know but when you have a
water moon which is
the water signs are cancer
uh scorpio and pisces and the water
placements are associated with intuition
with empathy
with really being able to emotionally
feel a situation so it's a lot of the
things that don't exist verbally but
just exist in vibes interesting and you
have a chart that picks up on vibes you
have a very vibe heavy chart you have
the thing where you can walk in a room
and you can feel like oh something's
going on here what's going on you know
we have it and that's that's energy
right yes but not everybody feels that
it shows up in the chart in different
signatures now you have your moon in
scorpio in the 12th house which is
the area of the chart associated with
psychic powers yeah
so you knew that i did know that
you're like yeah this isn't go on next
time no but it is isn't that fascinating
just for that confirmation i always do
the psychic thing where i think the
thing and then it happens or i think of
the person than the phone rings yeah
it's your super power really mm-hmm
really do i get a cape oh yeah okay
some sort of uniform would be nice
anything
yeah i'm really glad that you know that
you're psychic because oftentimes people
will feel the way that they feel you
know especially if you have a chart that
is as intuitive as spiritual as
connected as yours so what do you do
with that energy it's hard for some
people yeah but i'm glad that you're
harnessing it and working with it
because it's part of you i started doing
the thing that we're all like text my
friend when i think something i know
it's going to happen just because i want
like proof because you can only say like
i just said that so many times without
like concrete evidence so now i'm
starting to like
like text people so i can have it so you
have the the receipts yeah the receipts
you need that obviously yeah okay
another thing i think is interesting is
that i think that you can talk to ghosts
[Music]
so i'm like
i'm like whoopi goldberg and ghost like
i can if you want to be the way that
your moon is positioned and some of the
other planets that are in aspect to it
say to me that you have an ability to
connect with the other side
did you know that no i mean well i live
in manhattan and i can get a sell signal
like only 80 of the time so how am i
supposed to communicate with those who
passed over well that's actually also
very interesting to me too because that
also often happens when you are
energetically charged is you're going to
have weird technology stuff for real yes
it's all adding up
i'm actually
can't log into my facebook
what is a two-part authenticator
this is um fascinating yes so okay so i
need to harness my continue to harness
my psychic ability and then practice
talking to those who have crossed over
yes you know you are you're such a gift
and i'm so glad that you come on on our
show and share it with us and share it
with the entire audience this was like
riveting and can i take it with me yes
the chart of course please thank you
please enjoy look you guys this is my
chart like how cool anything else i
should know anything else you want to
know i think i probably already know it
oh
he's psychic
that's right
thank you so much
[Music]
you